okay uh let's get started uh as usual
with a quick review of a previous
lecture so last time we started looking
at the system architectures for the two
main types of lidar which is the direct
detection lidar and querying detection
lighter or coherent lidar in short and
the main the main difference is is
basically the signal that that that you
receive after uh the the conversion from
uh Optical signal or photons to the
electrical signal or or electrons so
specifically in a direct detection lidar
these systems employ a a simple photo
detector and as we know the photo
detector uh the signal that you get out
of it is proportional uh to the to the
incident uh Power or intensity of the
light so if you have some uh received
basically signal waveform which we call
S R which is the attenuation Factor
Alpha times the delayed transmitted
waveform SST of T minus Tau times the
Doppler shift e to the J2 Pi f d t we
showed that as it passes through the
photo detector which is the photodiode
plus the transimpedance amplifier in a
coherent detection system the signal
that we get out we call that SPD of T is
just some constant times the square of
the transmitted pulse which is delayed
by the round trip time of flight so you
get some Capital times s squared of T
minus Tau remember the the transmitted
waveform St itself was some
generated waveform s of T times the
carrier e to the J2 Pi of C so that
carrier term also vanishes through this
conversion effects so we get a signal
that is just a constant times the square
of the transmitted pulse shape
which is delayed by the round trip time
of flight and as you see there's no
phase information so it's a purely real
signal there's no phase information it's
intensity only and uh because of that
these systems all they can do all the
information they have essentially from
the signal that they receive is this
round trip uh time of flight Tau so so
they can only do ranging but they cannot
for instance measure Doppler shift and
from that deduce uh or estimate the the
velocity then we started talking about
the the more advanced type of lidar
systems which is coherent detection
lidar and these systems as we said they
employ a more complex optical receiver
which is called a coherent optical
receiver and coherent optical receiver
is basically uh what you get out of them
is a a signal that gives you is
proportional to the full complex
waveform that was transmit that so again
if the input signal to the optical
receiver this is the same as the the
direct detection letter so you because
it's the same physics of of wave
propagation so you get some attenuation
Factor times the uh delayed uh
transmitted uh uh signal times the
Doppler shift and out of the coherent
optical receiver you get this scrft
which is some constant times the full
complex basically waveform which is uh
your uh signal delayed by the round trip
time of flight or a waveform delayed by
the round trip time of flight times the
Doppler term e to the J2 Pi FDT so this
signal model is identical to for
instance what we had for CWU Radars and
from this now we have information so in
principle we should be able to estimate
both the round trip time of flight Tau
which as we know is proportional to
range as well as the Doppler shift FD
which as we know is proportional to the
relative radial velocity between the
Target and the and the lighter so you
get the full complex field where you
have both phase and amplitude
information and today we'll see uh
basically what type of waveforms
coherent lidar sends and receives and
then how the DSP Works to estimate range
and velocity basically so as you can see
uh coherent lidar is a a more uh
Advanced type of a system and
it can in principle do more than just
ranging it can also measure the velocity
but today most of the lidars that are
that are deployed are direct direct
detection there are some coherent
detection lighters also but the reason
is uh for I mean that's that's how
basically technology Works more complex
systems they just have a longer you know
time to Market there's more r d involved
in this start more complex systems are
less robust more expensive so that's why
direct detection lidar hit the markets
Market first now it it has penetrated
quite a lot in the market but we are
seeing you know an uptick of deployment
of coherent lighter systems and that's
why we study them and then we also said
in terms of the waveforms of coherent
lidars uh it's it's kind of like what we
uh looked at for for the case of radar
so you can do frequency modulation so
you can have fmcw coherent lidar which
sends basically uh chirps as waveforms
linear frequency chips or you can have
phase modulated systems that can use for
instance ranging codes like PMC w radar
or like ctfm sonar or similar to uh GPS
as well so the concepts should be very
very familiar by this point in terms of
the type of waveforms and how each are
processed but we'll see there's there's
some subtle differences uh in in this
case that that we'll talk about today
okay so
so
about the signal processing and coherent
lighter systems today and as we said
they their CW systems so they
continuously transmit a laser waveform
they can be frequency or phase modulated
uh with with periodic waveforms very
similar to CW
radar and we can build basically fmcw
lidars or pmcw lighters and the
difference is and the types of waveforms
that are generated and transmitted and
received now when it comes to the signal
processing algorithms for coherent lidar
principle there very similar to CW radar
but there are two main main distinctions
one of them
makes the DSP easier the other one is is
a complication but it's not too bad to
handle what makes it easier is that as
we know that the beam patterns for
lidars these are these gaussian beams
which are extremely narrow and
collimated so most of the time the
return that you get or the echo that you
receive is only from a single Target
because the beam you know spot sizes is
very small so it just hits a single
target comes back it's kind of like
you're pointing a laser pointer you know
out to the world most of the time it's
going to just hit a portion of of a
single surface
unlike the case for radar where for
instance mimo Radars if they use these
micro strip antennas as we know they
transmit very very wide beam patterns so
the returns that you get that are coming
from you know everything out there you
can get tens or hundreds of of targets
echoing back to you simultaneously and
that was a complication for the DSP it's
not the case for
lidar you can safely assume that there's
there's just you know one or a couple of
returns
okay so that's the nice thing uh the
other thing which is a complication for
lidar is that when it comes to Doppler
shift
um as we will see
um the the Doppler shifts experience uh
for for lidar for the same Target
velocity are much much much larger than
what a radar sees
um so it could be
um three orders of magnitudes for
instance larger Doppler shifts were the
same velocity and uh if you remember for
instance when we were developing uh
lidar DS radar DSP fmcw radar DSP for
instance we use the fact that Doppler
shifts very small so specifically if we
assume that within one trip time uh we
can we can ignore Doppler shift because
because it's much smaller than the
frequency shift that is induced by just
just the range effect and and that we've
kind of baked in that assumption into
DSP development for for radar now that
doesn't hold for lidar and we'll see
today how we should how we should handle
that so so again this is one of those
cases where
um it's it's very very important to know
you know when it comes to developing DSP
what assumptions are made and why they
are made and and what they imply in
terms of you know what we can and cannot
do okay so uh before we look at the DSP
I just want to make a small note about
signal attenuation in in specifically in
coherent lighter so every type of sensor
active sensor we talked about sonar
radar
and different types of light are in the
signal model there's always some
attenuation Factor Alpha that that we
just you know we we added there we kind
of we didn't do much much with it okay
but for instance if you want to estimate
the signal to noise ratio of of one of
these systems or if you want to run you
know physically accurate simulations
it's important to to estimate what that
Alpha is okay now it turns out that
um although we didn't go too much into
the details of it uh in every case we
have seen up till now estimating Alpha
is is kind of pretty straightforward we
kind of did it for radar if you remember
that radar range equation that we
developed that that was kind of
indirectly estimating this Alpha we also
kind of did it for sonar when we
analyzed you know the full uh return
signal model uh so so in those cases if
you refer back to how it was done it's
it's pretty straightforward you know you
just make assumptions about the forward
pass and the return Echo and the you
know the the reflectivity or the cross
section of the target so you just you
know it becomes a bunch of
multiplications that that you do and
that can give you you know at the end of
the day whether with a round trip uh
signal path how much attenuation you get
now when it comes to coherent lidar it
turns out that uh estimating or modeling
this Alpha becomes uh very tricky so
there's there's very deep physics that
that that goes into it and we can't
quite get into the details of it because
even you know at a high level discussing
why it becomes complicated uh to to
estimate Alpha for coherent lidar
requires knowledge of things like the
speckle phenomena and Optics and a
concept which is called the back
propagated local oscillator or BPL so
it's Way Beyond the scope of this course
or or maybe any graduate course it's a
kind of a thing that like if if you're
doing PhD research on this topic you
would go and you know figure it out but
I just wanted to mention that it's not
impossible but it gets you know really
uh complicated to estimate the S to
correctly estimate SNR of of coherent
lighter
okay so with that now
um let's start looking at the DSP of
coherent lidar and I want to start by
looking at the Doppler shift because I
did mention that Doppler shifts in lidar
are are much larger than what a radar
would see and that becomes a
complication for the DSP so remember uh
the Doppler shift is given by this
equation here so minus 2 VR over Lambda
over Lambda is the wavelength and VR is
the relative velocity relative radial
velocity between the Target and the
receiver so it's r dot where R is the is
the is the range basically from
transmitter to receiver
now if we plug in some ballpark numbers
for lidar let's say you have a 1550
nanometer lidar that's your Lambda and
VR is 45 meters per second okay so it's
fast but it's not outrageously fast I
mean it's a kind of a velocity you can
easily get if if you have some
lidar in a vehicle or something like
that and then your developer shift turns
out to be
-58 megahertz for for for for these
choice of parameters now for the same
choice of velocity if you calculate the
Doppler shift for 77 gigahertz radar it
it so that's just a different Lambda
right so here Lambda becomes about four
millimeters or so plug that in your
Doppler shift becomes minus 23.1
kilohertz right so notice notice that
almost like a thousand X difference
between the Doppler shift you get in
lidar and the Doppler shift you get in a
77 gigahertz radar for the same velocity
right so if you had the lighter and the
radar on the same robot simultaneously
measuring the same scene the two can
measure or see or experience very very
different Doppler velocities in the
return signal now because the FD is so
much larger the Doppler shifts are so
much larger for the case of lidar
we cannot make the Assumption we made
for radar so again for radar we made the
assumption that the Doppler effect is
negligible within every period of the
waveform and by every period I mean for
instance where fmcw we set every one
chip that you look at you can kind of
ignore the dopplers if you just down
convert it and the instantaneous
frequency you get from one chip is just
proportional to range and for to find
out where we were looking at multiple
chips within a longer time period which
we called a frame so that's what we did
for radar for lidar we cannot do that
because even with such large Doppler
shifts even for one period of your
waveform if you just again if you're
doing a fmcw lidar if you just look at
one chirp within that chirp time which
could be just microseconds the Doppler
effect is so significant that it cannot
be ignored okay so
um mathematically now we need to solve
for lidar a joint estimation problem we
need to simultaneously estimate both
range and velocity or both range and
Doppler shift it becomes a joint
estimation problem that cannot be
decoupled like we did for radar
um okay so that sounds like a big
challenge but it turns out that uh folks
came with a a very
smart trick in waveform design to solve
this and what they did is that
what is common practice in fmcw so now
we're talking about fmcw lidars
frequency modulated
coherent lidar so
in the case of radar if you remember the
the chips that uh were transmitted there
were these sawtooth-like patterns in
terms of like free instantaneous
frequency versus time it would ramp up
and then drop back to the um you know
start point and then go again so it was
it was a Sawtooth pattern now for lidar
uh what you can do is that you can you
can transmit triangular chip waveforms
So within one sharp duration you first
round pop your frequency linearly and
then ramp it down okay mathematically
you can write it like this so your
entire chip duration if it's uh T
seconds you break it into
um you know two halves within the first
half uh period you you send this way for
me to the J2 Pi FC plus b over to BT
over two times T so that's just you know
a linear up ramp in frequency and then
in the second half within a one-tier
period uh you ramp down your
instantaneous frequency okay so then uh
and the the time uh waveforms kind of
look like this as you see it starts with
a lower frequency in the middle
it goes to very high frequency and then
towards the end it goes back down so you
kind of go up go down and frequency
instantaneous frequency versus time as
you see here looks like these these
triangles okay now
um
so so with this now something very
interesting happens
um if we look at now the receive signal
model with this choice of waveform which
is triangular tubes instead of Sawtooth
I mean signal model we already know what
it is so uh in time domain the time
picture is this so you send some
waveform that's the green one again it's
a it's a triangular chip and what you
receive is a delayed and attenuated and
Doppler shifted version of this okay
exact same as fmcw radar but if you look
at the instantaneous frequencies of what
you transmit and what you receive now
you have this very interesting picture
on the right hand side where the green
is again what you transmitted so you
start at Time Zero from zero to T over 2
you ramp up
on your green uh and then from T over 2
to T the second half you ramp down the
blue is the instantaneous frequency of
the received signal
and now two things are happening within
just one uh chair period uh there is a
round trip delay Tau okay so that we
already know of exactly like radar but
also no notice that the blue is is is
shifted also vertically so the
horizontal shift is is your round trip
delay but there's also a noticeable
vertical shift because of Doppler right
so the starting frequency of your blue
is not FC but it's FC
plus F Doppler right because your
Doppler shifted so you also shift up
down according to to Doppler and it's
non-negligible I mean this effect we
also had for radar but we just said the
upshift is so small we just ignore it
right that's that's what we did for fmcw
radar here for lidar we cannot right so
it's not that the physics changed right
it is it the physics is the same we had
this effect for radar also but it was so
small at those frequencies that we
ignored it here we cannot ignore it now
uh if you calculate the difference
between the instantaneous frequency of
what you transmit and what you receive
with this triangular choice of uh chip
waveforms as you see during the up ramp
of the two-way forms you get some
difference Delta F1
and during the down ramp you get a
difference a different value of delta if
we call that Delta F2 right one could be
smaller the other one could be larger
and it turns out that if we somehow
estimate both Delta F1 and Delta F2 from
that we can calculate both range and
velocity okay and that's all all we need
to do so let's see what the signal model
looks like with this choice of waveforms
and then we'll see the DSP so
um just how the the fmcw lidar uses
these signals so uh it feeds the
transmitted chip signal as the Lo input
or the local oscillated input to the
coherent receiver okay so the Korean
receiver remember has two inputs so the
Lo input is is basically the the field
amplitude times the transmitted chip
ah given by this and the and the the
second input to your coherent receiver
is just to receive uh basically Optical
field which is the attenuation Factor
times the field amplitude times the
delayed carrier times the delayed uh
transmitted chip times the Doppler shift
right every term should make sense in
this now these two basically we know
that the coherent receiver it kind of
works like the that the down converter
for uh in in RF so it basically extracts
you know the uh the the the multiple the
conjugate multiplication of the of the
two inputs that that you feed to it so
uh we can solve that
um so we can we can basically find the
coherent receiver's output signal and uh
just if I go back so we're gonna break
it because because there is a up ramp
and a down ramp when we want to
calculate the output of the querying
receiver we can break it into two
calculations so first we look at this
part the operand part which is from Tau
to T over 2 okay and that's where
there's a frequency difference Delta F1
and then we look from Tau over from T
over 2 plus Tau
so this would be T over 2 plus Tau to T
so we look at this portion then and
that's where there is a frequency
difference Delta F2 okay if we do that
different separately so the math is just
more tractable okay so let's look at the
first part so that's the remember that's
the up ramp
part of the
um
transmitted and received signals and
what comes out of the coherent receiver
is some constant times the received
waveform times the conjugate of the of
the transmitted waveform okay this is
exact same as radar so I'm not going to
you know go over all the steps we know
how this works there's two basically
complex exponentials that get multiplied
out for the for the chirps and then a
bunch of terms cancel out at the end
once you simplify it it becomes equal to
some constant call that mutility one
times a complex exponential which is e
to the J 2 pi Delta F1 t as expected
right just from the from the visual
inspection we expected this scr to have
some frequency Delta F1 but what's
interesting is that
Delta of 1 is equal to your Doppler
shift minus B times Tau what is b b is
the slew rate
and tau is the round trip delay
okay and then mutility one is is just
some complex number doesn't doesn't
really matter it's it's a it's a
constant right it doesn't doesn't
there's no time dependency for it now if
you look at the second half basically
the down ramp part of the
transmitted and and received tube so
that's where tau is between two t is
between t over two plus Tau and and T
and you do the same thing again uh the
signal you're getting out of the Korean
receiver is a constant times uh received
signal times the complex conjugate of
the transmitted waveform and again uh
you do the simplifications it's it's
it's very straightforward math it's a
multiplication of two complex
exponentials but after simplification
what you get is some constant times e to
the J2 Pi Delta f 2 T and here your
Delta of 2 becomes the Doppler shift
plus beta okay now compare these two
and you see one of them is FD plus beta
one of them is FD minus beta so if we
estimate Delta F1 and Delta F2 very
easily from that we can find both Tau
and FD you just add them and divide by
two that's your FD and you subtract them
and divide by 2 times B that's your Tau
right it becomes a linear system of two
by two equations
any questions so far
okay so now we have the full received
signal model
again let's look at it graphically so
it's uh the math was a bit dense but
this is the same picture we had the
transmitted and the received signals and
uh they they get fed into the coherent
receiver and this scr of T that you you
get out if you look at the instantaneous
frequency of that signal it's equal to
some value Delta F1 between Tau and T
over 2. right that's the first part we
that part let's call that scr1 of t Okay
um
so that's just mu 1 e to the J2 Pi Delta
F1 T between Tau and T over 2 and then
from T over 2 plus Tau to T in this part
that's where we have scr2 of T which has
an instantaneous frequency Delta F2 okay
and that's rscr 2 of t and what are the
instantaneous frequencies Delta F1 is FD
plus beta Tau and Delta F2 is FD plus
beta
okay so now with with this now that we
know exactly the the the signal model
that we get out of the coherent receiver
for for this specific choice of a
waveform which is the Triangular chirps
uh now what what we uh we basically have
scr1 and scr2
and if we estimate the instantaneous
frequencies of those two portions there
are just two portions I'm calling them
one and two but they're it's it's one
time series signal that's coming out but
uh first half is it's called scr1 second
half we call that CR2 so kind of break
it into two shorter basically time
series signals but the point is
and C or the instantaneous frequency of
these two
from that we get Delta F1 Delta F2 and
then from Delta F1 Delta F2 we can with
very simple you know algebra we can get
the Doppler shift and the round trip
delay or or the the range uh how do we
do how do we estimate frequency same as
we have done before for radar and sonar
simplest algorithm is what it's the
Fourier transform okay so
um here we need to do two Fourier
transforms because we have two portions
of the signal so you kind of like
separate them out uh and and it's done
on the on the digitized signal of course
uh so passes through the ADC we get scr1
of N and scr2f and this is the
discretized version of the signal out of
the coherent receiver and note that this
is just one received chip right so
unlike the case of radar where we had to
you know build these big
data matrices or data cubes for mimo
systems and then you know process a
whole frame for lidar it's it's easy
it's like one chair pin one target out
one chip and one target out so it's it's
much shorter you know much smaller
channels you need to you need to process
so you do your scr1 scr2 do an fft on
each of them
and then you get scr1 of kscr 2 of K out
of the fft and then you look for peaks
in the ffts right the expectation is
again because most of the time for each
chip you're just getting returns from
one target each of these ffts should
show a one Peak right
very rarely you can get returns partial
returns from multiple targets and and
that's a complication that cannot be
easily handled for uh fmcw rate lidar
but uh it's safe to assume almost always
you just get one Peak from each of these
ffts so here I'm I'm overlaying the two
plots of the two ffts in red and blue uh
for a cr1 scr2 and each has a peak one
of them called that the peak index call
it K hat one and the other one uh called
the peak index K hat2 because the
Doppler shift can be positive or
negative
the period of the fft that we took we
take it symmetrically so the indices can
go from minus n over 2 to n over 2 minus
one so we look at both positive and
negative frequencies when we are
searching for K hat 1K at two and as we
have done for radar we can map the
indices in the ffts to the actual Delta
frequency so the Delta F the frequency
corresponding to each of these Peak
indices is just the K hat divided by the
number of points in the fft times the
sampling rate yes
um for really how do you get rid of like
there's still like the cost of my
carrier term when you mix it
um
the way in the uh in the in the coherent
receiver so it gets basically uh mixed
down to baseband
um and uh the the if you want the full
um you know derivation of how that
happens it's in the notes I'm just gonna
refer you to if you start
here where we start talking about the
optical coherent detection
um so so
we go through the full thing you know
that that
from from the ground up basically we
build the full model for the optical
coordinate detector but the point is
that at the end of the day uh that
signal where is it it's here the full
signal that you get the carrier term is
canceled out but the Doppler term
remains in it again exactly like a down
converter in in RF
um so so it brings the signal down to
baseband I mean basement plus Doppler
basically but but the carrier vanishes
out of the out of the coherent receiver
uh okay so
so that's it uh right so you do break
the signal into two sections do two ffts
find Peak you get your two peaks and map
the indices of the two peaks to
frequencies and then you have your
basically Delta have F hat one and Delta
have had two
um out of the peak search
okay uh so how do we find range and
velocity now that we have the two Delta
F's uh very simple right because uh
remember we had something like Delta f
one was equal to FD
I think minus beta and Delta f 2 was FD
plus beta right
double check this but I think that's
that's what we had so uh if you want to
find uh for instance Tau
or tauhat becomes equal to Delta f 2
minus Delta F1
divided by 2B right and and R or R hat
is just c times Tau hat over two
um so if we
plug that in it basically becomes c
times Delta of 2 minus Delta f 1 divided
by 4B or if you'd like to write it in
terms of the indices of the peaks in the
Doppler you can also do that and that's
the expression c times the sampling rate
times K hat two minus k at 1 divided by
4 and B where Big N is the number of
points in the ffts that we took so
that's your range in meters
and just like that you can find your
relative radial velocity which as we
know is minus the Doppler shift times
Lambda over 2
and then what is the Doppler shift f d
or F hat D is equal to Delta F1
or Delta F hat one plus Delta of two
divided by two so plug that into here
you get Lambda plus Delta of 1 plus
Delta f 2 over 4 or again if you like
you can write it in terms of the indices
of the two peaks in the two ffts and
that's your velocity in meters per
second again what assumption the main
assumption we made here is that because
the gaussian beams are very narrow
uh uh we assume that each received chip
contains Echo from at most one target or
in other words the assumption is when
you do these two ffts each of them has
at most one peak in it it can have no
Peaks if there was no return but we are
assuming at most small Peak it can
happen that uh rarely they have a couple
of peaks in them and then that becomes
an ambiguous case because you cannot
establish correspondence between the two
peaks in one fft and the two peaks and
the other fft basically and in doubt
those cases at least with this setup you
cannot find the two Targets
unambiguously
questions
okay so so this is it the DSP for fmcw
lidar is is essentially much simpler
than fmcw radar and and for two reasons
one was a smart choice that uh has been
made for the choice of waveform this
triangular you know uh waveform really
really solves this problem of the strong
coupling between the Doppler shift and
the and the and the time of flight delay
um if you if we were to work with
Sawtooth chips like
um uh radar it would have been much more
complicated but also the second thing
that made it uh really simple the DSP
was the fact that it's just one return
or one target you're looking at so per
chip so you just process one return
cheap chirp at a time uh and and you
know a lot of the complications
associated with radar for instance fmcw
radar just don't happen like you don't
need to work with these large data cubes
and so on and so forth
okay very quickly
quickly and also find the the minimum
range and velocity
discrimination or range and velocity
resolution if you will and and as we
know exactly like the case of radar when
you're when your frequency estimation
algorithm is a fft
um the minimum frequencies that you can
discriminate is one fft bin right so or
another way to think about it is if if
you look at if I clean things up here if
you're
R is given for instance by this
expression
the minimum you know discrimination in
range is when for two different targets
is when K hat K Hat 2 minus K hat one is
equal to one and that means the two
Targets are just one fft bin away from
each other so so you can find your Delta
R Min which becomes equal to again you
plug in the width of one fft bin which
is FS Over N into your R equation so
becomes c times FS over 4 and B
um or you can write it in terms of the
the total chip bandwidth which becomes C
over 4B
remember the the total chip bandwidth
for for these triangular chips is
because we use only half of the full
chip duration to ramp up right so so if
you start at some frequency FC you go up
to FC plus b t over 2 so your chip
bandwidth which is the total you know
frequency range that you sweep uh is Big
B equals b t over 2.
for the case of radar because it was
just one up ramp your chip bandwidth was
B times T there was no over two but here
you have the chip bandwidth for the same
duration and same slew rate basically
and that you if you compare this to what
we had for radar you would see that
there's a factor of two difference
that's why because the the bandwidth you
get again for the same slew rate and
same trip duration is half in this case
because you need to ramp up and ramp
back down
velocity resolution same thing you just
uh you know the the velocity equation we
had in the previous slider we derived
you just look at that for how much that
changes when you change your Peak by one
FST bin and that's your Delta V and it
becomes Lambda over 2T and meters per
second uh the trade-offs are the same
exactly as fmcw radar so if you want
more velocity resolution for instance
what should you do increase B
so Delta R goes down you get sorry more
range resolution so that's more range
resolution if you want more velocity
resolution what can you do increase chip
duration or go to Shorter wavelengths
for instance
um
and that's that's what you can do what
about maximum on ambiguous range and
velocity so in this case they are
coupled so unlike the case of radar
where we had one fft4 range one fft for
for velocity here the same fft
essentially gives you
both range and velocity information so
you cannot independently determine your
unambiguous range and velocities in this
case again because the Peaks that you
get the frequency of them has
contributions from range and from
velocity but the point is for a given
fft the maximum Peak frequency you can
find in it Delta F Max is is half the
sampling rate why half because we look
at it two-sided so we search for Delta
F's that are between minus FS over 2 and
Fs over two and because of that the
maximum peak in each of those two
individual your ffts that you can you're
doing the maximum
frequency for the peak is is going to be
FS over two and that that's the maximum
detectable frequency what range and
velocity translates to well it depends
if everything is a stationary then all
of that Delta f is contributed to from
the range and then you can say
in a stationary world this is the
maximum range I can say sense if or the
other way around if you know you're
you're sensing something very close to
you but it's moving very fast from this
you can maybe determine what what's the
maximum velocity but they're they're
coupled right so you cannot
independently say maximum range maximum
velocity because they get coupled
through this
um questions
okay so
um
this is it about fmcw lidar you can also
build a pmcw lidar and we know exactly
how this is going to work it's the same
physics same architecture different
choice of waveforms and DSP right now
before we talk about this we are not
going to go into a lot of depth here
because uh well PMC wider to my
knowledge it has not been commercially
deployed yet although it's a very very
interesting technology and research you
know there's a lot of very interesting
research being done on it
for you know some technological reasons
mainly because it requires you know adcs
with very high sampling rate and the DSP
gets a little more complicated it has
not been commercially deployed now
that's today I'm sure you know well not
100 sure but I'm fairly confident in a
you know in a in a few years we're going
to see pmcw lighters deployed so it's
important to at least know the concept
and uh and and and and so you know if if
you decide to work on it or you if you
encounter it later in your career you
kind of know what the idea is behind it
are again main difference here is they
use different waveforms uh and
specifically they use ranging codes
and they're phase modulated so binary
binary phase modulated bpsk modulation
again exactly like uh
pmcw radar and GPS
and the waveforms that they they send
you can you can send any codes basically
with good autocorrelation properties
most common one is MLS or M sequences
um so so that's your underlying waveform
and then you phase modulate it and you
get basically a sequence of plus and
minus ones exactly like a GPS that
multiplies your carrier so this this
first term is the bpsk modulated uh
waveform which again is just plus one
n minus ones and then that's your
carrier term
um so the in time domain basically this
is what it looks like one code word is
just a series of plus ones and a minus
ones that are multiplying the carrier so
every time you go from a plus one to a
minus one you get like 180 degree phase
shift in your in your carrier
okay so that's that's
just and then the signal model on the
receive side is exactly the same as
fmcwu lidar because it's the same
physics so the signal you get out of
your coherent receiver is some constant
times the delayed transmitted
waveform times the Doppler shift okay so
you get attenuation you get a delay and
you get you get Doppler shift okay then
you need to you know digitize this and
do DSP on it uh to recover range and and
velocity or range and Doppler
where there is no Doppler shift if FD is
is zero we know exactly how this is
going to work uh you just uh you have
transmitted some code you've you have a
receive code which is delayed and
attenuated with respect to the
transmitter code but there is no Doppler
shift so all you need to do is just take
the cyclic correlation of the two
exactly as you've done in GPS and then
that correlation shows a Peak at the
round trip delay Tau okay very easy we
all know how this works but it gets kind
of complicated when you have Doppler
shift because as as we know uh for the
case of lidar Doppler shifts are pretty
big
and non-negligible
um so so you have to you know either
cancel out the Doppler shift or you know
jointly estimate it with range or or do
something about it now in this
in this case where there is Doppler
Shift 4 pm CW later lidar there's no
standard algorithm
as of today okay again because this is
still being researched there's ideas out
there and some of them have been proven
experimentally and and and and we know
we know they work but there's no you
know like textbook standard algorithm
that you have pmcw lid art this is this
is what you do step one two three and
and and and and it works okay so I'm
just gonna mention the ideas or some
possible approaches to how you could do
DSP for pmcw lidar in the general case
where you have Doppler first idea is
exactly the same thing we we did for GPS
right this was also a problem for GPS
remember GPS you had to jointly kind of
estimate your your range and Doppler or
the way the GPS receivers work uh it
would basically search
for for the Doppler shift and once they
kind of found it they would cancel it
out by by doing Doppler demodulation and
this should be all be familiar because
that's uh how the GPS work so you can do
that somehow estimate your your Doppler
and and do demodulation with it and then
after you demodulate your Doppler you
get something that is only a delayed
coding range a ranging code uh and and
and then you just apply a correlation to
that and do do range so that's that's
basically do do it the GPS way that's
one idea other ideas uh that are quite
interesting and I've linked some
research papers here one is there's some
algorithms in DSP which you can jointly
uh estimate range and Doppler pretty
interesting so you just formulate it as
a joint you know optimization problem or
another very interesting research track
is uh um
well you don't have to transmit M
sequences you can design
more mathematically Advanced waveforms
which for instance still have good
autocorrelation properties but they're
robust to Doppler shift so when you get
Doppler shift on them it doesn't destroy
the correlation properties as happens
for for M sequences and that's a very
very interesting research topic of you
know what kind of special ranging codes
you could do
um this area of you know code design is
is also it's not just for lidar even for
GPS
still today there's very active research
being done you know new waveforms new
code designs so a couple of days ago
there was a PhD defense here at Stanford
uh that that was about new code designs
for GPS which was very very interesting
to me
um so so just so you know it's it's it's
a it's a very active research area and
you can do very very interesting things
uh and and this domain
okay so um that's it about uh basically
coherent lidar so we we developed a
signal model we talked about fmcw and
pmcw Signal processing and waveforms to
do range and and Doppler estimation next
topic is direction of arrival or DOA
estimation for lidar but before we start
that any questions
okay so the only estimation I mean we
have kind of talked about it it's
extremely uh easy for for for for lidar
because it doesn't require DSP
essentially or maybe very minimal DSP uh
and uh we should talk about the two main
types of Lighters so if you remember uh
there's there's flashlight r
um which illuminates the entire scene
you know in one shot with a very wide
laser pattern and there's a scanning
glider okay now let's let's look at how
DOA is estimated in in flashlight or so
in flashlight or it's uh pretty easy so
on the receive side uh we have an array
of photo diodes kind of like a camera
sensor right that has multiple pixels
and then it has some Optics in front of
it and then on the transmit side they
they transmit a very diffuse wide laser
beam that illuminates a very large area
in the scene
and then the receiver essentially takes
an image of it if you will except
instead of a RGB image it's a
time-of-flight image so every pixel
measures time of flight but just by
looking at you know the the the way the
Optics work every pixel
in a in a receiver array of the of the
flash lidar
it basically
gets returns from a very specific
uh Direction in the scene which is like
if you look at pixel J the Theta Phi
which is the Azimuth elevation angle of
the returns that that pixel gets is is
fixed in the scene again exactly like
camera right that's that's how images
are formed every pixel in your camera
you can trace back the direction of the
Rays that hit it uh from the scene and
the way that is done you can just
connect the pixel to the to the optic
center of the lens and just Trace that
Ray so with Ray tracing you know exactly
um where the the the direction of
arrival of every pixel is and for as
long as the Optics is fixed and the the
placement of the
photo detector array relative to the
Optics is fixed that directions the
direction doesn't change so you just
basically have like a lookup table that
tells you every pixel what the DOA
associated with it is and and that's how
you do DOA there's there's no no DSP
required for flashlight on okay it's
just by geometry of the pixels and the
Optics and you know their geometric
relationship between the two which is
the distance basically
don't need any DSP it kind of depends on
the scanning mechanism and we know
there's like different scanning
mechanisms but basically again because
we're sending out uh
super collimated you know pencil-like
laser beams
um the DOA is the direction that the
beam scanner is pointing to okay so we
kind of know the doas we don't need to
you know estimate it from from the
returns like we had to do for for radar
uh so here's one example for a
multi-beam
uh spinning lidar uh so so so those are
the ones that we had one in class last
time and and we looked at it we know
they transmit multiple laser beams
simultaneously and each of the beams
coming out is pointed to a fix is
pointing to a fixed elevation angle so
those are fixed and never change so the
the the basically the FI the files are
determined by the position of the of the
lasers
here's how you can look at it so inside
the the lidar basically you have a stack
of laser diodes and a stack of uh PDS
okay so they're they're literally you
know stacked on top of each other and
each of them when it transmits there's
usually they they are pointed backwards
it hits a mirror and then comes out and
goes through the lens
um but and then there's two lenses one
for the transmit one for receive so if
you look at your laser diodes because
they're stacked uh and then there's a
lens in front of them each of them will
point to a fixed elevation angle
it has a fixed Phi and there's very
precise alignment between the
photodiodes and the lasers so that there
is correspondence like first laser it
points in some elevation angle Phi 1 and
the first photodiode also is looking at
the same elevation angle so the beam
that was transmitted by the first laser
the echo from it is received by the
first photodiode that's such that
there's you know no cross coupling
between the multiple laser beams and and
their corresponding returns so I have
the two stacks and it could be like any
number between 16 or 128 you know
typically lasers and and receivers and
each of them the the elevation angles
are just fixed and Hardware never change
okay what about Azimuth well the Azimuth
we know these systems spin around 360
degrees so at for each transmitted pulse
um you kind of by by looking at the
position of the motor you also know the
Azimuth angle and you just read that
back from say an encoder that's that's
on the motor and uh and and and that
gives you your Theta okay so the files
are fixed per laser or per PD and the
Theta you just read it back from from
your motor and that's how you do DOA in
a in a multi-beam scanning lighter
pretty much no DSP again it's very
simple I mean the dsps just read back
the state of the motor and see what
angle that is
okay one more example for for scanning
light or again there's there's lots of
different
scanning mechanisms but the idea is the
same uh so for other uh scanners here's
like a mems one
um where it scans in both Azimuth and
elevation
again usually you have like a model for
the scanner well and what the model does
uh for you is basically it tells you the
Azimuth and elevation angles Theta and
Phi of the outgoing beam uh with respect
to the state of the scanner what do we
mean by the state ball it depends on the
scanner type but here for instance for
the memsa scanner we are showing here
the state could be you know the the the
state of the two actuators one of which
controls the pitch and the other one
controls the role of the mirror and if
you have some geometric model of this
you know pivoting Mirror by reading back
the state of the two actuators feeding
that to your forward model that tells
you the Theta and Phi of the of the
outgoing beam and that is basically your
DOA another example of this for instance
for a two gable system I think last
Friday uh went over the full details of
you know how you can build that
geometric model for a complex beam
scanner that has two mirrors if if you
didn't tune in and make sure you look at
the recording because it's a very
important and very interesting you know
example of how you can build this these
geometric models that tell you the DOA
for a specific choice of beam scanner
okay but it's a modeling effort it's not
DSP it's not dependent on your received
you know signals you just model it once
and use that model always just uh
feed the state of the scanner into your
model and the model predicts the angle
of the outgoing beam but it's important
to build the model because if you don't
build a proper model you can get
distortions in the point clouds that you
reconstruct because your Theta and files
are not accurately you know calculated
and that's it so DOA and lidar it's it's
it's very simple generally or in
comparison to a radar I should say it's
much simpler there's no you know added
DSP overhead but it requires you know
accurately modeling whatever beam
scanning method you're using and and
using proper models so you don't get
distorted Point clouds
okay
so we're pretty much done with the
discussion of lidar just just to recap
let's look at the end-to-end DSP
pipelines for different types of lidars
we discussed so starting with the direct
detection lighter so you get the signal
out of your photo detector and as we
know the way it can only estimate range
right and the way ranging works is that
it does the Leading Edge
detector or Leading Edge thresholding
and from that it estimates the Tau hat
or the round trip time of flight and and
you can convert that to range so you get
our hat and for DOA you basically get
that from your beam scanner either read
it directly back or or from the model
that you have that gives you your Theta
hat Phi hat and from the range and the
Azimuth and elevation angles you can now
build 3D representations in the form of
a say a point Cloud for instance and
that is the final lighter image that
comes out okay so that's your direct
detection lighter coherion lidar let's
say fmcw that we just talked about so
you get your signal out of the coherent
receiver you kind of break it into the
two halves we call that scr1 scr2 it's
the two halves of the of of the same
signal you do ffts on the two and then
you find the peak in each fft that gives
your Delta F1 or Delta and and Delta F2
and then by some very simple you know
math on Delta F on Delta F2 as we know
you can estimate range and relative
radial velocity and then the DOA again
you read it back from your scanner if if
it has read back or if not you have some
forward model and and from that you just
estimate what the pointing angle was for
your beam scanner and that is your Theta
hat if I hat and now you have range
velocity and DOA and then you can
produce representations usually in the
form of a point cloud and that's your
output lidar image
what about coherent pmcw lidar it's
slightly more complicated so you get
your signal out of the coherent receiver
there's different methods as as we said
here I'm showing the case where you
somehow estimate your Doppler shift
and then if you have an estimate of f
hat you can demodulate your signal with
the Doppler so basically exactly like a
GPS multiply it by minus J2 Pi F at D
um and that's now this St
of n is the signal with Doppler canceled
out so you can just correlate that feed
it to a correlation with the local
replica of the ranging code that you
sent and the correlation P gives you an
estimate of the round trip time of
flight and also you have your Doppler
estimation
from your Doppler block and from there
you basically get your range and
velocity estimate and DOA same story
right either you read it back or you
have some model of the beam scanner
which gives you the file the pointing
angle of your laser if I had Theta hat
and now you have range velocity and DOA
and you can generate Point clouds which
is your final lighter image so that's
basically the full the full picture for
different types of offline or that that
we looked at questions
okay
um so that's it um just just uh to recap
so lidar uh when it comes to 3D mapping
as of today is the most capable type of
sensor so you get the you know nicest
looking highest resolution
um type of uh 3D maps out of out of
lighter let's look at a quick video of
um something that's almost a state of
the art as of today this is a direct
detection lidar we're going to look at
and this is just a point Cloud it's
mounted on a car driving around
okay
for some reason
it's not going to full full resolution
um
but here you see it and and there is
this is just they're showing just one
frame so it's at 10 frames a second I
think and it's not like overlaying
multiple frames or doing slam or
anything like that as you can see like
things that are moving around there's no
almost no motion blur
um so it's it's a direct detection
lighter there's no velocity but they get
excellent uh reflectivity and they're
basically color here is reflectivity at
IR wavelength so they get very nice you
know intensity or reflectivity out of
this it's very dense so this one this is
a spinning lighter with 128
um basically scan lines uniform in in
elevation
um so so so this is what you can and it
sees up to I think two or three hundred
meters excellent resolution High frame
rate and so on and so forth that's the
state of the art today as you see I mean
radar is still today way behind this
um but lidar has its own uh its own
limitations right right and so one is
cost these lidars today are are
extremely expensive they're in you know
somewhere between you know five to
twenty thousand dollars range depending
on the specifics of the system one
lighter so very very expensive
um the performance as we know degrade
significantly in poor weather because of
the me scattering so if there's fog dust
rain snow those kinds of conditions can
significantly degrade and also at least
the direct detection type of lidar can
be prone or quite sensitive to
interference uh either from other lidars
or sunlight or you know any any type of
inbound interference can degrade some of
these lighters even if you have like two
of them in close proximity operating
they kind of blind each other because
because of the strong interferences so
again again you can get beautiful 3D
maps very high resolution and these are
very capable systems you also need to
know the limitations and that's why you
need you know other other types of
sensing modalities for for these
limitations uh coherent lighter as we
know you can get Superior performance
and it's getting more traction today
there are already you know commercially
deployed Korean lidars but not nearly as
much as direct detection today only fmcw
is deployed hopefully pmco will be
coming soon
um
equation systems today are even more
expensive than direct detection but
again there's lots of efforts underway
to make it cheap with specially with
better photonic integration uh hopefully
these systems can become cheap they can
they can estimate velocity which is very
very valuable for autonomy and that's
one thing that direct detection doesn't
do and there's tons and tons of ongoing
research on coherent Light Art
especially pmcw in terms of DSP waveform
design Hardware design it's a very
active area of research and
one of for instance very interesting
lines of research is that because you
have the full you know complex field
with the coherent lidar you can be smart
with your DSP and improve the
performance in bad weather and there's
some very very promising you know early
research results that show you can
improve a lot and and that's unique to
cohere and lidar because you need the
full field to be able to invert some of
these whether effects another one is
Advanced waveforms as we saw for pmcw
for instance they can help interference
they can you know make it more robust to
Doppler and so on and so forth
um fully solid state lidar which is you
know a lidar with no uh uh moving
mechanical components it's considered
the Holy Grail of of lidar uh doesn't
quite exist today there's you know some
versions of it with very limited
performance
um
but you know a high performing like the
one that we just saw fully solid state
light or does not exist today a lot of
progress has been made mostly you know
the last piece that needs to be solved
is beam steering right like a robust
high quality High performing Bean
scanning solid state thing with is still
doesn't exist as of today but a lot of
progress has been made and I'm sure
eventually we'll get there
something like you know Optical phase
array or something like that is is
needed to be able to do a fully solid
state lidar and and and again we don't
quite have it today but I'm fairly
certain we'll get there sooner or later
and uh and that's it about uh lidar any
questions yes
a performance and bad weather can be
improved by algorithms I thought that's
like a limitation of the wavelength well
it's a it's a limitation so so so you
still get
um you know all the one of the main
problems is is that uh false positives
right that you get in bad weather
because of the back scattered light
now it turns out that if your algorithm
is just a simple you know Leading Edge
threshold and you only have the
intensity of the light there isn't much
you can do you know you get a strong
back Reflection from a water particle
and it passes your infection threshold
and that's it that's a false positive
but one thing for instance you do with
uh with that we can do with the coherent
a lot of one is uh things like some
information in the phase and the
polarization can help you you know
distinguish you know what what the
return was coming from but also if you
capture the full wavelength uh so not
the full waveform
um and and uh instead of just deploying
a threshold you know kind of try to
extract more information from it in the
sense I mean it kind of depends on the
specifics of the waveform but for
instance in a pmcw system
one of the artifacts that you get when
there is you know fog and the weather is
you get very specific patterns in the in
these correlations and then you can have
smaller algorithms that learn those
patterns and so it could be some machine
learning based algorithm or even in
classical DSP you can you can do very
interesting things so so again it's kind
of like not just a DSP effect it's kind
of like a joint design problem of you
know waveform plus DSP plus a bit of
machine learning and you can be
much smarter in terms of you know how
how the whole system design is is done
and then they can they can again and
it's it's a I know my answer is a bit
wig because it's it's an active research
area so I don't quite have like you do
this this and that and whether it's
solved but the results that that people
have shown is is pretty impressive
already in terms of you know what what
you can do yeah
okay so uh
if there's no more questions we can
start the last chapter which is about
Imaging and vision sensors or or cameras
so uh this one is uh there's there's not
a ton of DSP in here although there's
there's a little bit uh but we mostly
will talk about you know uh the the
physics and the system architecture of
uh Vision systems as usual we start with
a bit of a history then we talk about
physics of Imaging lenses uh we talk in
detail about the digital image sensors
and then uh finally we we finish with
the system system architecture of of
cameras so what is Imaging uh Imaging is
uh process of capturing and recovering
visual quantities from light and what do
we mean by visual quantities so some of
these quantities can can be properties
of the scene
for instance an image can tell you
information about the motion of objects
color and reflectance of course is is
part of the that visual quantities that
you get out of out of images uh you can
even tell your identity of of objects
you can you know classify different
types of objects from a from an image or
you can recover properties of the
Observer and by by The Observer I mean
the the robot itself you can
recover things like ego motion like
what's the platform
um stable or static or was it moving and
looking at you know a few frames of
images from from a video camera can tell
you a lot about that or even the
orientation of the of the robot can be
deduced from images and finally you can
get uh information about the properties
of the medium
things like scattering effects as we
know Fog rain and things like that
immediately show in in images and and
and we can you know uh get quite a bit
of information about them Beyond just
you know the the visual you know
artifacts of the degradation and say
contrast
um you can you can actually uh extract
uh physical quantities of of uh of the
medium from images or the types of light
sources and and things like that now a
lot of research in in computer vision
for the past you know uh 20 years as has
been focused in developing smart
algorithms to to process images from
from these uh Vision sensors for
extracting these types of you know
properties that that we just talked
about so uh computer vision is a huge
huge field I mean you can teach multiple
graduate courses as we do here at
Stanford on on computer vision and
you're not going to quite get to any
depth regarding any of the specifics of
the algorithms that are used to uh
extract these types of information but
rather we'll learn about the physics of
image formation and cameras and how they
work okay that's the main main topic of
of discussion
so a bit of History so um
uh photography or Imaging started in the
1800s one of the oldest surviving
photographs is from
1826 by Joseph nissafor neeps I hope I
didn't butcher the pronunciation there
but it's called view from the window at
Lacroix which this is the picture I mean
by today's standards it's a pretty poor
image and note that this one is a
digitally enhanced version of the actual
surviving image so the actual one is
much less contrasty than this but
nevertheless it's it's a piece of
History because it was the first time
you know uh kind of like this Imaging
was was was done in a way that it
actually survived and how it was done
was uh he used a material called
bitterman of Judea which is kind of like
a natural asphalt material which is
photosensitive so it kind of hardens as
it's exposed to light and it was a metal
plate that was coated with that material
and then actually expose it for eight
hours so it took eight hours of exposure
to get that and then after the exposure
I had to you know wash off the unexposed
coating uh with lavender oil and
petroleum so it was probably like a
multi-day long effort to get just that
that one picture so that was where it
started shortly after that
um uh Louis De Guerre invented a much
much better uh Imaging basically uh
system that that that became commercial
actually
um so so that was 1839 and the technique
or the photographs that you you get from
it it was called the garrette uh it was
widely widely used in in the 1840s 1850s
and the way it worked was uh it used the
silver halide on a on a polished metal
and then you would expose it to to light
and then and a a image would form under
on the metal uh you would get the gear
type if they're done right and it's
difficult to do it right uh you get
images of exceptional exceptional
quality even like best cameras today
digital cameras cannot beat the gear
types in terms of image quality here's a
a a a an exceptional uh portrait of of
Abraham Lincoln
daguerreotype and the trick was I mean
there's there's lots of tricks in in the
gear types but they still require long
exposure time so the subjects need to
you know stay
perfectly still for
minutes sometimes sometimes less here in
this in this picture you would see you
know there's there's a bit of a blaring
on the thumb and that means probably uh
Lincoln got a little impatient uh during
the process uh but but nevertheless it's
a it's an exceptional image
um problem with the gear type is that
they're not you cannot make multiple
copies so you you know the original that
you get it's on a piece of metal and
that's it
um you cannot you know it's not
reproducible as in multiple copies in
about the same time a different process
was developed by uh by William Talbot uh
which was a from a commercial point of
view which was a much better Imaging
process and that one is called calotype
and it's it's basically where the modern
analog camera started so it was done on
paper coated with silver chloride and um
you could get basically negatives from
it and from a master negative you can
you can do multiple uh prints basically
so calotypes were uh was it was a better
process and that's why the gear type
eventually you know got phased out and
and calotype evolved into modern analog
photography here's on the right you see
a color type which was captured in about
the same time uh as as the as the the
gear type of of lingo
and then fast forward a few decades we
get to the Modern Age of uh digital
photography so the digital camera was
invented in 1975 at Kodak
which interestingly is a company that
almost got bankrupt because they they
did not get the value of digital
photography so it was invented there but
they decided to not even announce it uh
so so and that's a picture of the very
first digital camera interesting design
I don't know all the details but it
seems like they used a
cassette tape as you know to store the
images interestingly which kind of makes
sense it was 75 so you know modern
digital uh storage media didn't exist
but it wasn't until 1990s that digital
cameras became commercialized not by
Kodak actually Kodak almost entirely
went down because because they they did
not believe in the in the revolution of
digital imaging
then it was in
the sense that you know the technology
start becoming cheaper better performing
more robust smaller form factor and it
started becoming suitable for you know
dynamic platforms like robots so Imaging
for robotics kind of started in early
early 2000s so this was like a super
super quick uh you know
history of of Imaging and photography
but we're gonna basically just go go in
depth and talk about the physics of
image formation and especially digital
cameras how they work okay I think I
think this is a good place to stop
remember this was the last in-person
lecture so there's there's going to be
one more lecture which I will record and
upload uh on on Thursday and so we will
finish properly the the this chapter on
Imaging sensors and that's it thank you